في تطورات العمليه العسكريه تركيه
الشماليه السوريه افادت مصادر في المعارضه
السوريه المسلحه للجزيره ان الجيش التركيه
المتمركز في مناطقها الحدوديه الشماليه
سوريه استهدف مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في محيط عفرين بريف حلب وقالت
مصادر ومحليها ان طائرات مسيره تركيه حلقت
في سماء مدينه عين العرب الشرقيه حلب كما
تعرضت مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قريه اللبن
عيد عيد عيسى
في ريف الحسكه تعرضت بقصف من المدفعيه
التركيه التي استهدفت ايضا المواقع للقوات
نفسها في محيط الابيض بريف الرقه
وقد فزت وزاره الدفاع التركيه في تغريده
على تويتر افادت بمقتليمه وصفته باحد
ارهابيه حزب العمال الكردستاني واحداث
حمايه الشعب وقالت انه كان يتولى قياده ما
تسمى قوات تحرير عفرين في منطقه غصن
الزيتون